welcome back Hannity so in the wake of
the mass shooting in Las Vegas once
again members of the liberal mainstream
media have found themselves on Sunday
talk shows predictably pushing for more
gun control take a look the bump stock
thing might have affected this a
background check might have might solve
it for another particular either match
your regular background show but I think
that's what I'm saying one law is not
going to fix the whole problem a real
gun debate has to look at that fact the
300 million guns and we need to you know
look at what was done in a place like
Australia where they had a gun buyback
even the NRA accepts that you don't have
the right to have an automatic weapon so
what then is the constitutional limit
that says but you are absolutely
entitled to have a semi-automatic weapon
this is all kind of made-up mumbo jumbo
even though this is a win that everybody
agrees is something that is should be
done there's some people that are
concerned about what that means for the
next thing down the line would you then
go to semi-automatics where you didn't
get the background check legislation
that Democrats have wanted for a long
time joining us now is House Majority
Whip Steve Scalise who's still
recovering after being shot over the
summer and he's pushing back against the
left's efforts to politicize what
happened out in Vegas joining us now
Louisiana Congressman Steve Scalise I am
so glad to see you I just want you to
know and this audience's thoughts and
prayers were with you and I tried to
relay that to people on your staff how
you doing congressman I'm doing great
Sean and it's great to be back with you
I really appreciate the prayers we felt
them we received that from you and for
people all around the world it really
was uplifting at a tough time for me and
my family and the power of prayer can't
be underestimated as I said on the house
floor I'm a living example that miracles
really do happen because I saw real
miracles happen out on that ball field
and and even after that so uh it's I'm
lucky to be alive and it's just really
good to be with you I remember getting
an early report like a day two days
after and you had had a massive number
of blood transfusions and it was very
touch-and-go have doctors told you how
close you were to maybe not recovering
from this the
you know probably about a month after
when I was through all the surgeries I
asked my main trauma surgeon dr. Sava
said can you walk through with me what
really happened especially in those
first few days when I was unconscious I
didn't come to until about the fourth
day after I went to the hospital because
of all the surgeries and he said that
first day especially there were at least
two times where it could have gone the
other way and you know you look at look
at just getting to the hospital alive my
colleague from Ohio Brad Wenstrup if
he's not there a doctor a common Army
Ranger who who actually served combat
and helped get people to the hospital
from the battlefield he applied a
tourniquet that that slowed the bleeding
down and I would have bled out if I if I
didn't have that tourniquet applied
I don't what he wouldn't have even even
made what is your so what is your
recollection of the shooting
I remember hearing the first shot but
you're not thinking you were playing
baseball and you're not thinking there's
a there's a gunman shooting we're out on
a ball field I looked in a I saw a
tractor where the noise was coming from
and I figured maybe they detractor
backfired and then all of a sudden you
heard a few more shots and by that point
I got hit and went down and was hearing
a lot of gunfire back and forth that's
when my security detail
agents David Bailey they were amazing
engage the shooter they're truly always
there like they were there in an open
field with a pistol against a rifle and
yeah they were heavily outgunned but
look if they didn't have those guns to
counter the shooter it would have been a
massacre you know what he went out there
intending to do and if it wasn't for the
fact that he was confronted with other
people with guns he would have gotten
away with it and luckily for all of us
he didn't well you know I was really
heartbreaking last week I was in Vegas
and I interviewed a guy he was holding
his wife of 32 years hand when she got
shot in the back of the head and died in
his arms it nearly killed me I want to
play what he said to me the country
races into a big debate over gun control
you lost your wife
when you hear that and then maybe
juxtapose it versus what the president
said today what is the right thing for
the country to do and how to handle it
was a tragedy Sunday night I still will
never give up my rights
still never give up my rights I will
never give up my rights you were shot in
that field that day and you're saying
the same thing Dianne Feinstein said
this weekend I don't think there's any
set of laws that could have prevented
what happened in Vegas so what is your
answer to all of those that's so quickly
raised to politicize this well first my
prayers are with the families those
people at that lost loved ones and those
people that are still fighting for their
lives and what I said was in any tragedy
when you have a tragedy your first
thought ought to be how can we help the
people that are that are suffering the
victims of a criminal act like this how
you know let's pray for them first of
all in a case like what happened in Las
Vegas similar to what happened to me a
lot of those people needed blood I
called immediately for people to go and
donate blood and and yet unfortunately
you got some people their first thought
when they hear what happened is to go
and hold a press conference a call for
more gun control when they don't even
know the facts and frankly the things
that they're offering would have done
nothing to stop that that's shooting and
so why don't we at least in those
moments are our full thoughts ought to
be with with those victims and pray
inform because I felt the prayers those
prayers help me and I would imagine a
lot of those families are looking for
those prayers right now no congressman
we're glad you're well we'll glad you're
back we wish you a full complete
recovery and I still got a little ways
to go we're so glad you can come on
tonight and we're glad that you survived
that thank you for being with us